is that
it's kind of a new character park guy
it's just something i was playing around
with
are his shorts pulled up really high i
mean the normal amount but also he gets
his powers from them and is the
snakehead saying
i'm this way because i never learned to
read it makes sense for his character
all right i'm going back out i'm gonna
get that fish
we're going with you until bedtime
there's a fish
who's a beast from head to tail
it's become the park's white whale so
just call me
ishmael
let us go to tame the wild seed
time will tell what's meant to be and
we'll fight till we
are counted like a dad with a shirt be
brave when the moment comes to pass
this ain't no billy bass
[Music]
but if i do i hope you'll tell
my story and that's my dying
wish we'll always remember how you died
when you tried to catch a scary fish
i i got it you did it you really did it
and you didn't die
i like that i was gonna die i was gonna
die die trying
i didn't die trying didn't die trying
my team and i we woulda died died
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna buy that stupid park yes
you've mentioned that maybe i'll buy
that stupid newspaper too
that seems non-profitable but it would
be so pleasing to fire everyone does
someone need her
feel better juice i don't want to feel
better i want to
wait yes feel better juice would be nice
that helps too i'll buy the park or die
die
trying please die trying please die
trying
yes i'll get that stupid parker die
trying please pretty please pretty
please die
trying
and it's where
on earth
[Music]
[Music]
you